Queridos amigos, amigas, el eje franco-alemán
continúa liderando Europa pero ahora el equilibrio
de poder ha cambiado.
Angela Merkel ha tenido que lidiar con 4 presidentes
franceses diferentes.
Sin embargo, con la canciller alemana en retirada,
las posiciones francesas están cobrando fuerza
en Bruselas.
El discurso más incisivo que la Unión Europea
está adoptando en política exterior es una
ejemplo de esa influencia.
Pero sobre todo es la transición energética
el tema que se sitúa en el centro del debate
comunitario.
La transición energética y una pregunta
clave: ¿Cómo demonios lograr que la economía
crezca al tiempo que se acelera la descarbonización
y se reducen las emisiones de CO2?
Y mientras se buscaba una respuesta, el presidente
de Francia, Emmanuel Macron hizo este anuncio
que suponía ni más ni menos que romper con
el discurso político imperante en los últimos
años:
(Para garantizar la independencia energética
de Francia, para garantizar el suministro
eléctrico de nuestro país y lograr nuestros
objetivos, en particular la neutralidad de
carbono en 2050, vamos, por primera vez en
décadas, a relanzar la construcción de reactores
nucleares en nuestro país.)
El anuncio, a pesar de producirse en un momento
de fuertes tensiones con el precio de la energía,
ha sido sorprendente en la medida en que las
últimas centrales nucleares que está construyendo
Électricité de France no acarrean más que
problemas.
Así que la pregunta es: ¿Por qué Macron
apuesta por la energía nuclear?
¿Es la nueva generación de centrales nucleares
la solución al cambio climático?
Y lo que es más importante para todos: ¿Esta
decisión tendrá consecuencias para el resto
de la Unión Europea?
Hoy en VisualPolitik vamos a responder a estas
preguntas.
Pero antes, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
(LA POTENCIA NUCLEAR DE EUROPA)
La relación de Francia con la energía nuclear
viene de lejos.
El científico francés Henri Becquerel descubrió
la radioactividad y las investigaciones más
importantes sobre sus propiedades las realizaron
Pierre y Marie Curie.
Pero aún habría que esperar varias décadas
para poder aprovechar la nuclear como una
fuente de energía Concretamente hasta 1954
cuando empezó a producir electricidad la
primera central nuclear del mundo.
Fue en la Unión Soviética.
Entonces la energía nuclear parecía el futuro.
Así que a estos avances se sumaron pronto
el resto de potencias económicas:Reino Unido,
Estados Unidos y, por supuesto, Francia.
Estábamos ya en los años 60 y la mayoría
de los países industrializados habían construido
al menos un reactor experimental.
Poco a poco se iban desarrollando nuevos reactores
y así es como llegamos al año 1973.
Para entonces Francia tenía en funcionamiento
8 reactores nucleares repartidos en 5 centrales
diferentes, con 5 reactores más en construcción.
Y entonces, entonces llegó la crisis del
petróleo.
(Durante la famosa crisis de 1973 el precio
del petróleo se multiplicó por 4 después
de que los países árabes decidieran reducir
su producción.
En ese momento, la mayor parte de la electricidad
de Francia, un país sin campos petrolíferos
propios, era generada por centrales de fuel
frente a poco más del 5% que procedía de
la primera generación de reactores nucleares.)
De esta forma la conocida como crisis del
petróleo fue clave para se activara el plan
Messmer.
En marzo de 1974 Francia presentó al mundo
el plan con el que pretendía romper su completa
dependencia del petróleo extranjero.
El objetivo era convertirse en la mayor potencia
nuclear de toda Europa.
Este plan preveía construir en 10 años 80
reactores de energía nuclear y alcanzar los
170 para el año 2000.
Un plan que de haberse completado merecería
todo un capítulo de Megaprojekts.
Sin embargo amigos, la ejecución final fue
más modesta: se construyeron 58 reactores
en 19 emplazamientos diferentes.
Pero, de todos modos, un objetivo sí se consiguió:
Francia es tras Estados Unidos el país del
mundo que más energía nuclear produce.
Y, por supuesto, para Francia es su mayor
fuente de generación de electricidad.
(Prácticamente el 70% de la electricidad
francesa es de origen nuclear, el porcentaje
más alto de todo el mundo.
Además, dada la importancia de Francia en
la Unión Europea, sus 56 reactores operativos
contribuyen notablemente a que casi un tercio
de la electricidad consumida en el bloque
comunitario sea de origen nuclear.
Y, claro, como es una energía que se genera
sin emitir carbono a la atmósfera, Francia
quiere reivindicar la energía nuclear para
luchar contra el calentamiento global.)
Y sí, sé lo que muchos estáis pensando:
Bueno, Enrique, pero también las renovables
producen electricidad sin emitir CO2.
Pero claro, la cuestión es que, como sabéis,
la eólica y la solar dependen de las condiciones
climáticas.
¿Qué pasa cuando el viento no sopla?
Pues… La respuesta a esa pregunta es algo
que hemos visto en 2021 en toda Europa, cuándo
se ha tenido que recurrir incluso a las fuentes
de energía más sucias.
(Alemania: el carbón supera a la eólica
como principal fuente de electricidad)
Pues bien, a diferencia de las renovables,
la nuclear ofrece una producción de electricidad
estable.
Además, su precio se ve poco afectado por
las fluctuaciones en el coste del uranio.
Por supuesto, como todos sabéis, también
tiene sus inconvenientes: la gestión de los
residuos nucleares es uno de ellos.
Y no solo hablo de seguridad sino también
de coste.
Por ejemplo, en la propia Francia el coste
del proyecto Cigéo, un almacén geológico
profundo para los residuos radiactivos, se
estima ahora en unos 40.000 millones de euros,
muy lejos de los 25.000 a los que apuntaban
las previsiones iniciales.
Una enorme inversión que, sin embargo, es
tan solo la punta del iceberg.
R(El plan Messmer hizo que aproximadamente
el 80% de los reactores nucleares franceses
se construyeran entre finales de los 70 y
los años 80.
Con una vida útil de 40 años, esto significa
que o se invierte ahora en su renovación
para que continúen operando con garantías
o se debe afrontar su desmantelamiento.
Cualquier opción supone para Francia decenas
de miles de millones de euros.)
En concreto según las estimaciones de EDF,
el desmantelamiento de los reactores costaría
unos 75.000 millones de dólares, mientras
que la operación de actualización y puesta
a punto para que sigan operando unas décadas
más ascendería a unos 50.000 millones de
euros.
Y es esta última por la que finalmente ha
apostado el gobierno francés.
Pero ojo, porque de momento, Francia tiene
regulado por ley que su capacidad nuclear
no superará nunca los 63,2 gigavatios.
Así que, salvo cambio legislativo, cualquier
nuevo reactor, que es lo que al fin y al cabo
ha anunciado el presidente galo, supondrá
el cierre de alguno antiguo.
Eso es algo que queda por definir.
En cualquier caso hay otra cuestión interesante:
la industria nuclear francesa ha tenido muchos
problemas en los últimos años.
Así que la pregunta es, ¿Realmente está
preparada para el plan Macron?
Atentos.
(TIEMPOS DIFÍCILES)
Para hablar de la energía nuclear en Francia,
tenemos que fijarnos en 3 letras: EDF, las
siglas de Électricité de France.
Hablamos de la empresa pública que es dueña
de las centrales nucleares francesas y que
abastece de electricidad al país galo como
si prácticamente tuviera un monopolio.
También es propietaria de Framatome, el negocio
de reactores nucleares que la compañía absorbió
en 2018 de Areva, otra empresa estatal que
tuvo que reestructurarse ante los problemas
que la industria nuclear francesa ha tenido
en la última década.
(El regulador nuclear de Francia ordenó en
2016 detener 21 reactores, más de un tercio
de la flota nuclear de EDF, después de que
Areva reconociera defectos en 400 piezas fabricadas
desde 1965 y que eran utilizadas en los generadores
de vapor.
Los inspectores estaban preocupados por los
altos niveles de carbono hallados en el acero
de la forja de Le Creusot, con riesgo de fractura
en el acero en caso de un cambio brusco de
temperatura.)
Lo que pasó entonces fue una buena muestra
de lo que podría pasar si Francia renunciara
de repente a sus nucleares.
Las centrales térmicas se pusieron a quemar
carbón a un ritmo no visto desde la década
los 80.
Pero esperad un momento, porque antes incluso
que la atmósfera, el frenazo a la generación
atómica lo notó el bolsillo de los franceses.
El precio de la luz se disparó un 40%; pero
ojo porque también subió en buena parte
de los países europeos a los que Francia
exporta su generación eléctrica.
En 2017 las aguas volvieron a su cauce.
Pero la broma no salió barata: la estatal
francesa cifró en unos 1.000 millones de
euros el impacto en sus cuentas del cierre
y la reparación de las plantas.
Lo peor de todo es que si ya este incidente
es grave de por sí, el gran dolor de cabeza
que todavía hoy día atormenta a EDF es el
reactor europeo presurizado, el EPR; un reactor
de agua presurizada de tercera generación
que a principios de siglo se presentaba como
el proyecto estrella de la industria nuclear
francesa.
Han pasado los años y actualmente solo hay
2 EPR en operación.
Están en China y uno ya ha tenido que parar.
Entre 2022 y 2023 está previsto que empiecen
a operar otros EPR en Finlandia y en Francia,
concretamente en la central nuclear de Flamanville.
Podría hablaros de todos los problemas que
ha arrastrado el EPR de Flamanville, pero
casi mejor que os lo cuente el ministro francés
de Economía, Bruno Le Marie.
Tal y como decía el ministro, todo estos
problemas y sobrecostes han sido un duro golpe
para la reputación de Francia en el campo
de la energía nuclear.
Hace años Reino Unido era el principal interesado
en seguir invirtiendo en energía nuclear
e instalar los EPR de la estatal francesa.
Las cosas hoy son diferentes.
Sí, un proyecto ya está aprobado pero, como
es lógico, a los British se les están quitando
las ganas de hacer más pedidos.
(Los dos reactores EPR para ampliar la central
nuclear de Hinkley Point acumulan varios años
de retraso y millones de sobrecoste.
Su precio se ha elevado hasta los 27.000 millones
de euros y no entrarán en servicio hasta
2026.
En el aire queda la aprobación de otros dos
reactores EPR de EDF para la central de Sizewell.
Parece que al final se inclinarán por dar
luz verde al proyecto después de 10 años
de debate.)
Precisamente Reino Unido y Rolls-Royce acaban
de anunciar una inversión de 400 millones
de libras para desarrollar y diseñar una
nueva generación de reactores nucleares más
pequeños.
Hablamos de los SMR, Small Modular Reactor,
con una potencia que no supera los 300 megavatios
frente a los más de 1.000 MW de los reactores
convencionales.
Lo interesante es que Rolls-Royce asegura
que “más pequeño” será sinónimo de
“menos problemas”.
M(Se espera que los SMR sean más baratos
y más rápidos de construir que los reactores
existentes.
Su coste se estima en 2.200 millones de libras,
con expectativas de reducirse en el futuro
hasta los 1.800 millones de libras.
Los SMR están diseñados para ser producidos
en masa desde una fábrica y luego transportados
a su ubicación definitiva.
Su construcción, que duraría entre 3 y 4
años, promete ser más sencilla que la de
los reactores EPR, que tardan más de 10 años
en ejecutarse.)
Francia también está atenta a las evoluciones
de los SMR.
Un mes antes de anunciar la construcción
de nuevos reactores, Macron comprometió una
inversión de 1.000 millones de euros para
el desarrollo de estos SMR.
Se ha dado cierta confusión porque algunos
medios llegaron a vincular ambos anuncios.
Sin embargo, no está nada claro que sea así.
De hecho es muy probable que el plan Macron
se corresponda más con lo expuesto por un
informe encargado por su propio Gobierno que
se filtró en 2018.
Nuclear: un informe recomienda la construcción
de seis nuevos EPR)
Se espera que estos 6 EPR cuesten un tercio
menos que el EPR de Flamanville y que 50.000
millones de euros sean suficientes para construirlos
todos.
El objetivo sería aprovechar las economías
de escala.
EDF asegura que sus próximos EPR se beneficiarán
de las reducciones de costes a medida que
se construyen más copias del mismo diseño,
una ventaja de la que los actuales proyectos
no han podido beneficiarse.
Al menos esta es la teoría.
Para que se haga realidad será muy importante
la evolución tecnológica pero especialmente
que Francia tenga éxito en la batalla que
está librando en Bruselas.
Y este amigo es otro punto clave.
Bienvenidos a la burocracia comunitaria.
(QUID PRO QUO)
La Unión Europa está a punto de tomar una
decisión vital para afrontar la lucha contra
el cambio climático.
Sobre la mesa está la llamada taxonomía.
Seguramente muchos sabéis que la taxonomía
se encarga en la biología de clasificar a
los animales y plantas en función de sus
características.
Pues aquí lo que pretende la Comisión Europea
es decidir qué fuentes de energía se clasifican
como ambientalmente sostenibles.
(La idea es que la taxonomía se convierta
en un principio rector para la Unión Europea
a la hora de decidir qué industrias pueden
ser subvencionadas.
También se pretende que la taxonomía sirva
de guía para los mercados financieros al
valorar en qué fuentes de energía merece
la pena invertir.
`Por tanto, el futuro está en juego: o acceso
a subsidios y capital barato o una financiación
mucho más complicada en caso de quedar excluida.)
Como os podéis imaginar, Francia está peleando
con todas sus armas para conseguir que la
energía nuclear entre en los planes de Bruselas.
Y lo más importante es que no están solos.
Junto a Francia se han posicionado Bulgaria,
Croacia, Eslovaquia, Eslovenia, Finlandia,
Hungría, Polonia, República Checa y Rumanía.
Además, estos países también contaron con
el apoyo de Países Bajos y Suecia en el último
Consejo de Ministros de Energía.
Hablamos de 12 de los 27 miembros de la Unión
Europea.
Pero esperad un momento, porque otros países
no están dispuestos a ponerle una alfombra
roja a la energía nuclear.
El grupo opositor está liderado por Alemania,
que en 2022 culminará el apagón nuclear
que anunció tras el accidente de Fukushima.
Le siguen Austria, Luxemburgo, Dinamarca,
Portugal y España.
Y de hecho lo que está haciendo Berlín es
pelear porque sea el gas natural el que se
clasifique como ambientalmente sostenible
ya que emite menos CO2 que la quema de carbón,
que actualmente es una de sus principales
fuentes de energía.
Ahora bien, la pelota está en el tejado de
la Comisión Europea, que obtuvo de las instituciones
europeas un acto delegado para definir el
marco de la taxonomía.
¿Y qué piensa la Comisión?
Pues así se pronunció a finales de octubre
la presidenta Ursula Von der Leyen.
Esta propuesta de taxonomía se presentará
como un acto delegado.
Solo hay dos formas de que no salga adelante:
que se pronuncie en contra la mayoría del
Parlamento Europeo o una mayoría cualificada
del Consejo Europeo.
No parece una tarea nada sencilla.
La pregunta es, ¿estará Bruselas dispuesta
a enfrentarse a Berlín?
Así que todo indica que nos encontraremos
con un acuerdo Quid pro quo.
Es decir, algo a cambio de algo.
Alemania cederá por un lado; Francia cederá
por el otro.
La Comisión Europea clasificará tanto al
gas como a la nuclear como “ambientalmente
sostenibles” y todos contentos.
Diplomacia made in Bruselas en estado puro.
Pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros: ¿Creéis
que Francia al final logrará que la energía
nuclear reciba la bendición de Bruselas?
¿Os gustaría que vuestro país también
pusiera en marcha un plan para construir nuevos
reactores nucleares?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Como siempre, si te ha resultado interesante
el vídeo dale a like y no olvides suscribirte
a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.
Para garantizar el suministro eléctrico de
Francia, lograr ser más competitivos y alcanzar
la neutralidad de carbono en 2050, Emannuel
Macrons acaba de colocar a de nuevo a Francia
en la carrera por el desarrollo nuclear.
El país galo, el país en el que más peso
tiene la energía nuclear de todo el mundo,
construirá nuevos reactores durante los próximos
años.
Y eso no es todo, también está peleando
duro para que la Unión Europea considere
a la nuclear como una energía verde y sostenible.
En este vídeo os contamos todos los detalles
sobre la reciente apuesta de Francia por regresar
a la era de los átomos.